Le ballon officiel de l’EURO 2016 est le
« beau jeu ». Regardez-le de près.
Vous remarquez quelque chose ? Il n’a pas
la forme du ballon de football classique,
vous savez, le noir et blanc...
Et ce n’est pas le seul, le Teamgeist, le
Jabulani et le Brazuca eux non plus n’étaient
pas faits de pentagones et d’hexagones.
Et le ballon de la première coupe du monde
non plus !
Mais du coup.
Pourquoi les ballons de football ont la forme
qu’ils ont ? Pour comprendre, il me faut
de la manière dont ils sont fabriqués.
Depuis le début du 20ème siècle, on utilise
des espèces de feuilles de cuir ou de plastique,
que l’on coud pour former des formes aussi
circulaires que possible.
Et bon, pour les premières coupes du monde
comme celle de 1930, ça fait des grosses
coûtures dégoutantes…
Et puis, en 1970, pour la coupe du monde la
plus mythique de tous les temps, Adidas a
introduit un tout nouveau design qui allait
marqué l’Histoire de l’humanité.
Enfin, l’Histoire du ballon rond.
Bon okay, juste l’Histoire du foot.
Mais pour ceux pour qui le foot est une religion,
le ballon de 1970 d’Adidas est vraiment
l’équivalent d’une croix pour les chrétiens…
Et pour un matheux footeux… oui ça existe.
J’en connais.
Même très bien.
Bon okay je parle de moi…
Pour un matheux footeux, je dois dire que
la géométrie du ballon de 1970 est fascinante,
notamment parce qu’il est le résultat,
conscient ou non, d’un merveilleux raisonnement
géométrique.
Reposons le problème du design d’un ballon
de football.
Celui-ci consiste à coudre des morceaux de
cuir plats pour former une figure aussi sphérique
que possible.
Pourquoi sphérique ? Parce que les grands
joueurs veulent pouvoir dribbler en levant
la tête, ce qui nécessite d’avoir une
balle qui réagit de la même manière, peu
importe quelle surface de la balle touche
le sol ou le pied du joueur.
Vous savez ? Pas comme le sport que certains
appellent football bien que le pied ne soit
quasiment jamais utilisé pour taper dans
la balle…
La bise à mes amis québécois…
Et donc, si on n’a pas tout à fait une
sphère, il serait bien que le ballon soit
au moins le plus régulier, le plus symétrique
possible.
Or les figures faites de faces plates les
plus symétriques qui soient sont bien connues
des mathématiciens depuis l’Antiquité
! On les appelle les solides réguliers, ou
solides de Platon.
Off.
Les solides de Platon sont des volumes dont
les bords sont des faces plates toutes identiques
aux côtés égaux, et dont n’importe quel
sommet est identique à tout autre sommet.
Et le plus surprenant, c’est qu’il n’y
en a que 5.
Trois de solides ont des faces triangulaires,
tandis que les deux autres ont des faces carrées
ou pentagonales.
Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi donc n’y a-t-il
que 5 solides de Platon ? Réfléchissez-y.
Comment cela se fait-ce ? Ça dit, ça non
? Se fait-ce ? Marrant…
Off.
Pour définir un solide de Platon, il faut
et il suffit de choisir le nombre de côtés
des faces et le nombre de faces par sommet.
Ceci dit il y a deux contraintes à vérifier.
Pour commencer, il doit y avoir au moins trois
faces par sommet, car sinon, on ne pourrait
pas replier les faces de sorte à former un
volume.
Mais dans le même temps, la somme des angles
autour d’un sommet ne peut pas égale un
tour complet ou plus, pour une raison similaire.
Off.
Si l’on s’impose des faces triangulaires,
le nombre de faces à chaque sommet peut être
3, 4 ou 5, auxquels cas on obtient respectivement
un tétraèdre, un octaèdre et un icosadère.
Si l’on choisit des faces carrés, on ne
peut avoir que 3 faces par sommet, et ceci
nous donne le cube.
Idem si l’on choisit des faces pentagonales,
auquel cas on obtient un dodécaèdre.
Et c’est tout.
Car si on choisit des faces avec 6 côtés
ou plus, il devient impossible de mettre trois
faces ou plus par sommet sans excéder 360°.
Revenons-en maintenant au problème du design
d’un ballon de football.
Le plus sphérique des solides de Platon est
celui a le plus de faces.
Il s’agit de l’icosaèdre, celui fait
de cinq triangles par sommet.
Oui, mais l’icosaèdre n’est pas si rond…
Ses sommets sont pointus, et ça, ça peut
être génant pour rendre les trajectoires
des rebonds prévisibles.
Pour rendre l’icosaèdre moins pointu, les
designers d’Adidas ont alors choisi de trancher
les sommets.
Et ce que l’on obtient quand on fait ceci,
c’est un solide fait de pentagones et d’hexagones,
ce qui correspond au…
roulement de tambour… ballon de 1970 ! Oui
! Le ballon de 1970 est donc un icosaèdre
au sommets tranchés, que l’on appelle en
mathématiques l’icosaèdre tronqué.
Et depuis 1970, l’icosaèdre tronqué est
devenu le symbole du sport le plus populaire
de la planète !
Pourtant dès 1978 et le Tango, les dessins
d’Adidas sur ses ballons n’étaient plus
forcément ceux d’un icosaèdre tronqué.
Alors, avant de vous parler du Tango, je vais
insister sur la géométrie des dessins.
Si l’on prend par exemple un ballon de ligue
des champions, on pourrait croire a priori
que le dessin sur le ballon n’a rien à
voir avec l’icosaèdre tronqué.
Et pourtant, tout ce qu’Adidas a fait, c’est
remplacer les pentagones par des étoiles
à 5 branches.
Mais au final, on voit clairement se dessiner
sur le dessin d’Adidas les empruntes de
l’icosaèdre tronqué.
Pour le Tango de 1978, si les coûtures du
ballon était bel et bien un icosaèdre tronqué,
ses motifs dessinés par dessus étaient ceux
du dodécaèdre.
Et oui, si on oublie les coûtures et si on
ne regarde que les dessins, on voit 12 faces
pentagonales ! Et ces faces pentagonales semblent
en parfaitement harmonie avec les coutures.
Mais pourquoi donc y a-t-il une telle harmonie
entre un dodécaèdre, et une figure dérivée
de l’icosaèdre ? Et bien, il se trouve
que si on prend un icosaèdre et si on met
un point rouge au milieu de chacune des faces,
et si on trace des arrêtes qui lient ces
points rouges, on obtient exactement un dodécaèdre.
Plus fou encore, si l’on fait ça au dodécaèdre,
on obtient l’icosaèdre.
On dit que le dodécaèdre et l’icosadère
sont les duaux l’un de l’autre.
Alors, petit exercice du coup.
Quel est le dual du cube ? Joignons les milieux
du cube.
Vous voyez ce qu’on obtient ? Et oui ! Le
dual du cube est l’octaèdre.
Et en fait, le dual de l’octaèdre est le
cube.
Enfin, le dual du tétraèdre… et bah c’est
lui-même.
Le tétraèdre est son propre dual.
Du reste, pour vérifier tout ça, il suffit
de se rendre compte que le nombre de faces
d’un solide est le nombre de sommets de
son dual.
Le cube a 6 faces et 8 sommets.
L’octaèdre a donc 8 faces et 6 sommets.
Enfin, les nombres des arrêtes sont les mêmes
entre un solide et son dual !
Bref.
Tout ça pour dire qu’en fait, de 1970 à
1978, à la dualité près, tous les ballons
de foot et leurs dessins reposaient sur la
géométrie de l’icosaèdre.
Mais depuis 2002, Adidas s’est mis à innover
géométriquement.
Pour commencer les dessins du Fevernova de
2002 reposent sur la géométrie du tétraèdre,
ce solide fait de 3 triangles par sommet.
En effet, si l’on considère que chaque
illustration est un triangle, on voit que
les dessins forment les faces d’un tétraèdre
régulier.
Ou, et ça correspond à la dualité, si chaque
dessin représente un sommet, on voit se dessiner
le tétraèdre régulier dual.
Et pour le Roteiro de l’EURO 2004, les dessins
d’Adidas se sont reposés sur une autre
géométrie.
Vous voyez laquelle ? Il s’agit de l’octaèdre,
ce solide fait de 4 triangles par sommet.
Mais, comme le Fevernova avant lui, et comme
tous les ballons qui le précèdent, le Roteiro
n’a d’octaédrique que les dessins.
Ses coutûres, ses faces en cuir, elles, reposent
encore sur l’icosaèdre tronqué.
Et puis vint la coupe du monde 2006…
BUT DE ZIDANE
En 2006, Adidas présente au monde le Teamgeist
qui repose sur une nouvelle géométrie.
Le Teamgeist, lui, est en fait un cube tronqué.
Il a donc 14 faces contre 32 pour l’icosaèdre
tronqué.
Et ça, ça veut dire que le Teamgeist nécessite
moins de coûture, ce qui permet d’enlever
les irrégularités dues à ces coûtures.
Pourtant le Teamgeist est plus rond que l’icosaèdre
tronqué...
Vous voyez quelle était l’astuce trouvée
par Adidas ? La clé, c’est de rendre les
côtés des faces... arrondies.
C’est pas trop fou ce qu’ils ont fait
Adidas ?
Et ce n’est que le début.
En 2010 donc, Adidas introduit le Jabulani.
Ce ballon est un tétrahèdre tronqué.
Et ça, ça veut dire qu’il a 8 faces.
Mais en utilisant la même astuce des côtés
arrondies, Adidas a su en faire un solide
toujours plus rond ! En fait, beaucoup de
joueurs ont critiqué le Teamgeist et le Jabulani
pour avoir des trajectoires imprévisibles.
Et bien, il semble que cela puisse s’expliquer
par le fait que ces ballons sont plus ronds
que les précédents, ce qui pourrait créer
plus facilement des perturbations de l’air.
Et puis vint la coupe du monde 2014 au Brésil...
5-0
En 2014, Adidas introduit le Brazuca.
Regardez-le de près.
Pouvez-vous deviner la géométrie du Brazuca
? Et bien, le Brazuca a 6 faces, 8 sommets,
3 faces par sommet…
Et oui ! Le brazuca est un cube ! Un peu comme
tous les ballons officiels de 1930 à 1966
d’ailleurs…
Off.
Voici les surfaces du brazuca, et voici comment
elles sont collées.
Vous voyez ? C’est exactement le patron
d’un cube.
Et ça, c’est parce que le brazuca est un
cube, dont les arrêtes sont vachement arrondies.
Mais alors, les coins du cube ne devraient-ils
pas être pointus ? Non ! Et ça, c’est
parce que les angles des faces du brazuca
font 120°.
Mettez trois angles de 120°, et vous obtenez
un tour complet ! Vraiment, je vous l’assure,
le Brazuca est une merveille mathématique.
Je vous invite à aller ce superbe article
d’Étienne Ghys sur Image des Maths pour
vous en convaincre.
Qui plus est, en plus d’être une merveille
de géométrie, le Brazuca est aussi une merveille
technologique, comme l’explique cette superbe
vidéo d’ESPN.
J’attendais avec impatience de découvrir
la géométrie du Beau Jeu, le ballon officiel
de l’EURO 2016.
J’ai été déçu.
Adidas a juste repris la forme du Brazuca
et changé les couleurs et les dessins…
Bon, il faut dire qu’ils font souvent ça
pour les coupes européennes.
Je garde
donc l’espoir d’une nouvelle innovation
géométrique pour la coupe du
monde 2018.
Combien de faces aura alors
le
ballon officiel d’Adidas ? Je vais parier
4…